let's go uh why don't we go next to yoel
or yell from Ontario Canada our friendly
neighbors to the north what's going on
is it yoel
can you hear me yeah I can hear you fine
my question is um do you think it's
possible to be an ethical consumer in
today's globalized society
yeah you know I've gotten you it wasn't
you who called with this exact same
question like a month ago right
no it was okay yeah so okay here's
here's the thing let's assume the answer
is no you can't be an ethical consumer
in this Society then then what do we do
what's what do we do based on that if
that were the answer just indulge me for
a moment let's say I said you know you
all you can't be an ethical consumer
right now nope what what would what
would you do
are you asking me personally yeah
um I guess you have to just kind of do
the best you can
um
that's why I'm asking you really is
because like for example the World Cup
was on recently yep and initially I was
going to boycott it out of obviously the
human rights violations of yeah vibrant
workers dying or whatnot but then I
realized my hypocrisy was for example
if I go to England or Germany or
whatever those World Cups and those
leaks still sponsor I take sponsors from
Nike and Adidas and other companies that
still exploit workers and in China and
Bangladesh and whatnot right so it
almost seems like no matter what I do
I'm in I'm in a I'm just being a
hypocrite you know I'm just yeah and
choosing what I think is personally
important to me I know exactly what
you're saying this is the difficulty and
we've we need to find the balance
between
living completely off the grid and
isolating yourself from all of these
things which almost none of us are
willing to do I mean almost literally no
one is willing to do that or doing the
best we can to both make decisions we
feel okay it doesn't we don't have to
feel great but we feel like we can
accept the decisions we're making
and where we think things are not right
doing what we can as activists to affect
change so at the end of the day I mean
you make a good point I covered for a
decade leading up to the Qatar World Cup
there was corruption in how Qatar got
the World Cup horrible treatment of what
are essentially slaves building the
stadiums deaths and cover-up of the
deaths promises made by the qataris
about kosher food and LGBT people and
all these things that they went back all
this different stuff and I covered it
all along and then we get to the games
at this point the cake is baked and I
want to see Argentina you know I was
born in Argentina I want to see if
Argentina wins and and and Argentina won
and it was a you know great thing
um where where is the balance do I feel
okay enough with the fact that after a
decade of talking about how horrible it
was I watched a couple games you know I
do I'm okay with it in the grand scheme
of my life and everybody has to kind of
decide for themselves
yeah I kind of feel like in a sense it's
almost too much for an individual to
take the burden trying to boycott every
little thing I kind of think it relies
more so on us turning to International
organizations to kind of
um
place better restrictions on where you
know for example like
a lot of cobalt comes from slave Minds
in the Congo I think it's too much for a
burden for me to boycott all
rechargeable batteries because it's just
not a good life to live right
um I think it relies more so on the UN
and international bodies to sort of act
in our favor try and
um orchestrate some way where it's
reasonable for me to be an ethical
consumer it's not on me to just sort of
boycott every little thing because that
would just make my life miserable I
agree with that I also think that as
activists and voters we need to demand
of those organizations that they
actually do the things you're talking
about you know so so there's really an
element of all these things but I I
think you're thinking about this roughly
the way I am
right yeah just because I've just it
made me feel bad kind of initially
watching the World Cup but then I just
realized that like it's just too much of
a burden for one person to put on their
shoulders to try and boycott every
little thing that's wrong about the
world right especially such a globalized
economy
and that doesn't mean we give up and it
doesn't mean we don't care yeah I
appreciate the call you well thank you
thank you all right there's Joel from
Ontario great to hear uh from him very
very exciting stuff